we're missing a trick by saying all
males over there females over there
strange there's not that much
differences but that must be because we
haven't got a big enough sample or our
images aren't subtle enough we should
really forget about males and females if
we're interested in behavior let's look
at behavior
it's not to say that environment
postnatal learning plasticity isn't just
as important but some of those very
early biological factors might be might
be helping us understand why the two
sexes and experience risk differently
and if you look at the real research on
this and if you look at the data it's
very clear that men and women have
somewhat slightly different life
priorities there's they're fairly slight
differences
good afternoon
good afternoon thank you very much
everybody for coming along to this
session and if the size of an audience
and the I think the silhouette of
standing figures at the background to go
by the difference between men and women
whether it does or does not exist he's
going to be quite an interesting subject
so thank you all for coming and I'm
staying for what I hope will be a
scintillating 45 to 50 minutes that
really looks at the question I'll are
men from earth and women from Earth it
seems to be a central point of it on my
fridge for many years has been a lovely
magazine post couple of my favorite
postcards it's got men and women and
above men it's got a simple switch on
off and under women it's got dials knobs
arrows he'll readouts digital head-up
displays and everything and it does seem
to me that women are complicated am in a
pretty straight fall now is that the
kind of neuro nonsense that is really
being spouted out in this world well we
have three top boffins to talk about
this today and I will all and I don't
reduce them not necessarily in order of
annoying this but in order of what I
think is hopefully different ways of
looking the subject with me this is Gina
Ripon now Gina your professor of neural
imaging an astronaut you say so you're a
neuro boffin really aren't you yeah now
this lady is outspoken in what she
described as neo trash euro bunker euro
four-letter word these are things that
really I think some are big problems for
us and certainly for me as a
psychiatrist today and she spoken
outspokenly on that very subject with me
is mr. is Professor Simon baron-cohen
who is no less than a professor of
psychology at Cambridge University he's
an expert on autism but for me he's made
much much richer contributions to many
many debates about how far biology and
psychology can explain human nature can
it he's written many books on the
subject the essential difference I think
is your book that addresses the issue of
gender difference and also I think
you've written a book in in this country
it's called the science of Eve is the
American title isn't it yes zero degrees
of empathy zero degrees of empathy is
the English title so
something and in the blue corner we had
Hellenic Ronin
now Helen Ares co-director of the Center
for the philosophy of natural and social
sciences and she's a philosopher by
training but actually she's not really
she's that realize the things a
practical philosopher and her and her
way of being practical is through
evolutionary science she's an unashamed
Darwinist and I'll be hearing it from
Darwinism a little later I think but
first of all I want to give each of them
three minutes and once again you know
Chatham House Rules and timing rules
apply here Gina I'd like you to go first
I'd like you to tell us what you think
about this idea is there a difference
between men and women and easy.all
biological
well the question I was asked to start
with our mental differences based in
biology which really means our men's and
women's brains different and is this
what drives the differences between men
and women and have to say when I started
this I thought I really wish I wasn't
here not because hey is in a wonderful
place but because I think this is an
18th century question wonderful advances
in technology in the 21st century
amazing ways of imaging the brain
fantastic ways of looking at big
datasets and yet we're still asking 18th
century questions and still coming up
with 18th century conclusions I think
it's time we moved on so I mean I could
take my whole three minutes as an
academic unpacking the question saying
what do we mean by different I'll set
that aside for the moment but I do think
that we should be careful that lots of
people say well when I say different I
mean on average or these types are more
common in males and females I think we
need to be careful because I don't think
that's the message that gets out there
different for people means different
categories nice little box with you know
a switch or another box with dials men
women that's all we need to know and
then we know from that all the other
characteristics that we might be
interested in so we need to be careful
of that so just quickly in the remaining
two and a half minutes re-examining the
evidence and I'm saying re-examined I
think the evidence has already been
really examined but we still ignore it
and I think that's really what I'm
trying to say so we got three levels
we're interested in behavior men and
women behave differently
well do they there's a wonderful paper
came out recently with the title I wish
I'd thought of black and white or shades
of grey where somebody reexamined all
the so called psychological sex
differences which characterized men and
women and found that actually they're
not really categories if you have a
single dimension you'll find that the
scores of males and females are pretty
equally distributed along that dimension
so we shouldn't be thinking about
behavior in terms of categories and this
was like 120 plus psychological
characteristics including you know fear
of failure and masculinity and
femininity even
the other level we can look at is the
kind of cognitive skills kind of thing
that I look at at Aston looking at the
different kinds of processes that we go
through in order to understand the world
around us
big understanding there's differences
between males and females differences
males are very good at spatial tasks
females good at verbal tasks again if
you look at the evidence the difference
is a tiny and there's a nice paper by
Janet Hyde came out recently talking
about gender similarities showing that
actually men and women are much more
similar than different and yet we still
think about them as different and so we
need to think about why we still think
in that way and we also know culturally
speaking as we look across the world as
the gender gap in terms of education and
financial independence closes so
differences in in cognitive skills can't
be based in biology but at least at
least we say well we know we're on safe
ground when we're talking about
biological differences between males and
females excess chromosomes XY
chromosomes well fortunately for me then
if you can see this but this came out in
nature quite recently August a
scientific journal sex redefined saying
that actually we should really be moving
on from a binary district understanding
of sex even biologically males and
females aren't that different and I know
from the work that I've done that the
males are the brains of males the brains
of females really aren't that different
so just to conclude then it strikes me
when I look at this the history of this
kind of question and how its evolved the
scientists and and actually people who
still hang on to this difference show
controversially some kind of signs of
frontal lobe damage there's a task
there's a task called a perseveration
task where if you got damage to your
frontal lobe I won't go into details of
the task but you're asked to sort cards
into different categories and you're
told yes if it's a color category and
then the experimenter will change the
category and so actually it's the number
of shapes on the card if you've got
frontal lobe damage you still keep going
on with the color even though the
experimenter says sorry it's that all
doesn't even tell you its shape so
there's something about the difference
between males and females which makes us
stick to this old-fashioned binary
dichotomy I think we need to move on
so effectively I'm saying we need to
move on from the 18th century we need to
move on from the kind of Mars and Venus
concept and we need to say that there's
actually much more interesting much more
informative and much less harmful which
I'll come back to later categories than
thinking of males and females in terms
of male brains and female brains
so I'd probably start off by saying that
I agree with that with Drina yes don't
stop there
in there I think I think we are moving
towards dimensional approaches rather
than categorical approaches so male and
female as categories and not is not
really helpful that a lot of what you
can measure either psychologically or at
other levels biologically is showing
that a dimensional approach is more
useful that people are situated at
different points on dimensions a second
point of agreement is actually that um
any differences you find when you
compare groups of males and groups of
females are only quite small and subtle
and that the similarities are probably
more evident than the differences and I
suppose a third point of agreement is
that we recognize that biology and
culture contribute to any of these small
differences that are observed between
groups of males and females so the old
polarity and it's either biology or
culture really we we have moved on from
that and I would still make a plea that
we don't ignore the role of biology and
I think this will come out in the in the
panel and that's because I'm very
interested in how sex differences emerge
first of all at the anatomic level we
know that in terms of reproductive
system development males and females
clearly clearly differ and the question
is what gives rise to those differences
and do those factors influence our brain
in our behavior so for me what's been
really compelling and reading the
scientific literature is that if you
start at the point of conception and you
look at the fetus in the first four
weeks of life the fetus has no anatomic
sex and no hormonal sex a male and
female fetus differs chromosomally gene
is already mentioned about XX or XY but
if you just looked at the anatomy of
that fetus you wouldn't see any
difference
but the presence of that y-chromosome in
males and in particular a gene on that y
chromosome called sry triggers a whole
cascade of developmental changes in
particular making the gonad which starts
offers what's called by potential it
could go either way
develop into a testes or an ovary and
cutting a long story short the presence
of the testes produces much more of a
hormone called testosterone in males
than in females and the secretion of
that hormone doesn't just change the
fetus anatomically in terms the
reproductive system but that hormone can
also cross the blood-brain barrier and
change the development of the brain and
the development of behavior so biology
is playing a role we'll come back to
this in animal research and you can
manipulate the amount of that hormone
testosterone to really show how it
changes the development of the structure
and functioning of the brain and
postnatal behavior but prenatal hormones
sex hormones like testosterone and
that's converted into estrogen really do
play part of the influence are on later
behavior what culture does and
socialization does is equally important
so I want to underline that my position
is an interactionist I think very
moderate position that culture and
biology interact but we shouldn't lose
sight of biology thank you
beginning with the fact that I once
heard a member of an all-girl street
gang boasting about how macho their
initiation ceremony was and the two
things they had to do was either get
beaten up or have sex with a male gang
now sex as a penalty imagine that for
the male gang
it's just laughable over evolutionary
time mating has bestowed very different
costs and benefits on males and females
and that's the key to understanding all
sex differences they've arisen from
different selection pressures on the two
sexes ultimately those differences stem
from different reproductive strategies
that was the very beginning of it sexual
reproduction involves dividing your
reproductive investment into two after
you left cloning and you've got on to
sexual reproduction in evolution that's
what you must do you must divide your
reproductive investment into two you
have to compete for mates and you have
to care for offspring throughout the
living world males specialize more in
caring in competing and females
specialize more in caring that doesn't
mean that's the only things they do they
specialize more in it there's always
that difference some difference in the
ratio consider for example the
competitiveness a quick way to think of
it is give a man 50 wives and he can
have children galore give a woman 50
husbands no advantage whatsoever so
disadvantage so natural selection has
strongly favored men who competed really
strenuously for mates and all men today
are descended from victorious
competitors thus compared to women men
have always had far more to win far more
to lose which makes them vastly more
competitive for example risk-taking
single-minded status seeking
hierarchical ambitious opportunistic
entrepreneurial and so on more so in men
than in women
now when Matt
natural selection shapes psychology it
also shapes bodies to match so looking
at physical competition the strengths
that's most crucial for physical
competition upper body strength is 75%
greater in males than in females that
really tells you something and comparing
male and female matching the psychology
and and the body's stronger men are
quickest to anger and feel most entitled
to whatever they want
by contrast anger and entitlement among
females matches not strength but you
probably guessed attractiveness
that's eloquent evidence of a different
evolutionary past precisely as predicted
by Darwinian theory okay but what about
claims about socialization boys toys
guns girls pink frocks no natural
selection doesn't build us to be putty
in other's hands anyone who could be so
readily manipulated about how to be a
male or how to be a female successfully
would never have become our ancestor so
sex differences in mentality have been
in the making for 800 million years if
they don't show up in neuroscience
it's a neuroscience that needs to get
real
well
open up this little can of work I mean
if I made you to come to you because in
many ways you know you've a said danger
to read too much into biology its deadly
but you know there's no we've heard
about morphology and powerful structure
and stuff like that it seems that you
know I think very very hard to believe
that biology doesn't dominate the
picture I mean and this our society is
hungry for good decent scientific
explanations your your professor when
you're imaging yourself I mean where
then there must be some crucial parts of
biology in all this well obviously is
cognitive neuroscientist sounds like
we're going to have this I agree with
silent yeah um of course I believe that
our behavior is based on biology but I
would say as I've been told to be
controversial I think what Eileen has
said it's an eighteenth-century idea
it's not all about reproduction this is
the idea that you know women shouldn't
go to university and get degrees because
it will affect their reproductive
ability it's way way longer sorry I
didn't ask you are you a mum I am I'm
sure lots of mums and dads in the room
and you know boys are different from day
one the way they act does they eat
things and punch and chew and smash and
I'll be surprised if in the utero the
the male fetus drinks more amniotic
fluid
but those clots people in society and
all this evolutionary stuff not be
standing is there the chance to cut in
yeah I think this is where we get into
category mistakes though saying it just
because on with all no really that's a
category yeah absolutely
back to reproduction of course but I
think where is the biology that's really
I mean what useful things can you know
you say that can actually take us out to
the edge rap affording the biological
pseudo explanatory so I think we to
remember that we're talking about mental
differences we're talking about why then
why there's a huge gender gap you know
the World Economic Forum produces a
global gender gap index each year no
countries have actually closed the cap
so we're actually thinking about what it
is that means that as with these kind of
measures males and females experience
the world differently benefit
differently from the world is it really
just to do with reproduction or is it to
do with a particular attitude a belief
about what with men and women
do so themselves as well as the
attitudes of people out there so I think
a society is important I would say that
one of the things I think the 21st
century is shown is how plastic our
brains are our socio-economic status
will affect our brain explain what you
mean by plastic what I mean by plastic
is the way in which the brain yeah no
not far binos brain can change it used
to be thought that you know if you went
to medical school 30 years ago or
something you'd be taught that you're
born with a number of brain cells and
that's it and you goes through life and
your brain gets a bit bigger and life
will changes a bit as more connections
formed after the age of about 50
unfortunately you know brain falls off a
cliff the gray cells start disappearing
etc so it's it's that that used to be
the way the brain was thought of it I
taught thinking a bit about like a
vacuum-packed brain so this brain was
there and things happened but it was on
a kind of determined evolutionary
timeline whatever but we now know that
tiny things can change the brain much
more than than we thought possible and
we know that the brain can recover from
injury
so the quite dramatic changes can be
reversed but even quite subtle changes I
was talking somebody last night saying
that our socioeconomic status affects
particular character characteristics in
the brain well that might be to do with
health access to education etc but also
our perceived socioeconomic status so
where we think we are in the pecking
order can also change aspects of our
brain so when I say plastic and the role
of biology I think biology certainly
definitely can't not be involved but I
think we're not aware of how much
influence is brought to bear on that so
you're saying then that the world we all
go through male and female is constantly
shaping our brain structure as we go
along as though you're saying yes
because I understand it's not rocket
we're born without God's quota of
neurons and then they're prudent within
the first 10 years of life I mean I mean
you happen to you on this side this idea
that that Gina suggested that actually
it's biology being batted around all the
time by the environment I mean yeah what
can your science bring to that well I'm
glad you've raised the the word pruning
because
during early development and the the
brain undergoes a lot of pruning that we
we form many more neurons than we retain
in development and we form many
connections between neurons and that get
pruned and the technical term is
apoptosis but it's also described as
selective cell death that when losing
neurons in early development and very
interestingly that hormone I mentioned
earlier testosterone reduces the rate of
pruning in neurons in the brain so given
that the male fetus and the female fetus
which as you said our category
differences you've got your Y chromosome
or you don't
you've got your sry gene or you don't
those are category differences that you
know you're you see as soon as that gene
is influencing how much testosterone the
fetus produces which is a dimensional
difference more or less testosterone
that hormone is affecting brain
development the number of connections
that you retain and you can see this
neuro anatomically so if you dissect the
brain you find that the male and has
about a third more neurons than the
female so these are just quantitative
differences that are the result of
biological fact but they're robust
findings are they those are robust
findings you can't doubt the existence
of the sry gene but this this
differential pruning yeah an original
thickness of the corpus callosum for
example you know the big highway between
the left and the right hemisphere he's
repeatedly different in women is it me
out no you're saying it's not okay
alright then so it may or it may not be
let's put this in oh that's what I said
there the boffins but but lets us try
then to drag this biology back into the
real world
throughout the petri dish and the
bleeping psychology screens into the
world of the boardroom salary what is
the role of neuronal pruning and
testosterone gee sry in existence of the
boardrooms invade the glass ceiling for
women in executive roles I mean how's
biology play into that slowly synthesize
these
these two views so I think I think the
the biological research um you know we
can learn quite a lot from animal
research particularly where you can
manipulate the gene you can manipulate
the exposure to the hormone prenatally
and see the effect it's happening having
on brain structure and brain function
but now you're jumping all the way yes
to human behavior i'm asking with a
biology within a myriad pieces of
tremendously useful wisdom can helpfully
inform an understanding of practical
social issues for example to do with the
sexism in female salaries v80 on tampons
it's everywhere you know i mean how can
biology take that further forward so my
view is that if we want a society that
is equal for the two sexes that's more
of a political issue and we we can
change our so biology is not going to
inform politics anytime soon well i mean
they're separate enterprises but when we
want to study the biology never this
angel they they they need to meet this
is why we're having these debates but i
think that first of all it's very
important to say that the research into
sex differences really only tells you
about group averages and gina made this
point right at the beginning it doesn't
tell you anything about individuals so
at the boardroom or at the interview for
the job if you have a male or a female
you can't predict or presume anything
about that individual based on their
gender and introduced they would be
stereotyping and discriminating so
biology has really to do with the real
world as we knew because campaign sorry
yes i don't let campaigns to get more
women on board the concept of the glass
ceiling is all about averages that's
what it's about
of course the idea of when somebody
comes to an interview that's about
individuals so you shouldn't look at you
shouldn't ask are they male or female if
it's meritocracy alone that you're
concerned with you might be concerned
with whether they're male or female for
other reasons for example you might be
concerned about a jury in a rape case or
something of that kind these are very
delicate very difficult questions but
certainly if it's meritocracy that
you're concerned with then you shouldn't
care whether it's a male or a female you
look
what their CV says what their
performance has been but averages make a
huge difference and unfortunately they
are taken up royally in policy because
people deny there are sex differences
because they deny there are sex
differences they assume there's a glass
ceiling preventing women from getting to
the top and women are prevented from
getting onto boards those are bath those
are both in general and they assume that
and say it must be discrimination now
it's not discrimination if you look at
the real research on this and if you
look at the data it's very clear that
men and women have somewhat slightly
different life priorities there's
they're fairly slight differences
particularly compared to some species
particularly mammals in which the males
are hugely different both literally and
figuratively
from the females we're not terribly
different in lots of ways but these life
priorities make enough difference to get
more men in the boardrooms more men to
the top and for women to take jobs that
are paid differently and to do it more
often part-time to stay at allure level
willingly willingly that's what they
actually prefer because their life
priorities involve doing other things as
well can I just I think the trouble is
that you say we should be looking at
individuals not in terms of where they
males and females the trouble is that
out there the evidence we will look at
the evidence debating it a lot of people
believe really believe there are
differences and we know that if you have
Seavey's same CVS with a male or a
female name on then the male depending
on the job it's more likely that the
mayor will be given a higher salary etc
etc so I think the trouble is that
people really believe there are
differences and they behave
appropriately and that's why the
boardroom decisions are made in the way
they are and just to pick up on
something else that Mark said in terms
of biology affecting policy when I was
doing some research into neuro trash I
came across his wonderful book called
inside her pretty little head with a
pink cover and it was all about it was
for marketing people and it was all
about the neuroscience no it wasn't
unfortunately
it was about how marketing people should
cash in on what neuroscience had shown
about females being different and how
they could adjust their marketing
activities appropriately so I think
that's what I'm really saying is we have
to be really careful you know we can sit
in this nice tent and nod and say it's
you know on average and women are more
like this and men and women are more
similar but actually that's really not
what's informing a lot of activity in
the outside world but what you'd be
saying then is that group differences or
never usefully inform individual
differences and that in turn means that
biology is a precious little reverenced
about day to day lives so why why they
pay your salary doing research you guys
you know we know it's it's guaranteed
headlines and stuff is we really
interested in can't read maps it's all
in the interior semantics we're still
talking about males and females if we're
interested in map reading let's look at
map reading if we really need to know
how people read maps people might they
don't I just pay my salary to get people
to read maps but actually for my point
of view that could be really quite
useful but that's where we're getting
into difficulties we're missing a trick
if we're looking at all these really
interesting aspects of behavior that all
our wonderful science techniques all the
wonderful images we have in the Aston
brain centre plug plug means that we can
actually look at these and we're
spoiling we're missing a trick by saying
all males over there females over there
strange there's not that much
differences but that must be because we
have got a big enough sample or images
aren't subtle enough we should really
forget about males and females if we're
interested in behavior let's look at
behavior so um well I to the question
does it does it matter and why is it
important why are they paying our
salaries yeah oh no so I'll give you two
examples where I think it matters so I
work in the field of autism and so it's
a neurodevelopmental condition and where
people develop disabilities and very
interestingly those children and adults
who struggle to socialize and
communicate and the majority of them are
male and one of the reasons that took me
into the field of sex differences and
gender differences was to try to
understand why
certain clinics see far more boys than
girls autism is one good example a
second example is language disabilities
children who are late to talk someone
mentioned prisons so again important
areas of our society where we see very
significant differences in the sex ratio
of who ends up in those clinics or in
those prisons and the other example I
was going to give was I'd already been
mentioned about universities what do you
study at university and when you look at
the applications into subjects like
mathematics engineering computer science
physics you see far more males applying
for those subjects and being given
offers to study those subjects than
females if you look at Sciences like
medicine psychology veterinary science
you see the opposite profile far more
female applicants and more offers now
going to females so to me this is
telling us that there are some
interesting differences when you look at
big data large data sets across for
example UK universities or at US
universities for the two sexes are equal
in terms of scientific aptitude but
they're choosing to study very different
sorts of things that males are more
likely and these are just averages more
likely to apply to study sciences that
had to do with inanimate objects or
systems and females are more likely to
study Sciences related to people or to
animals animal sciences so this may well
reflect and the I think what Helena
called the values different values that
we have been shaped by priorities life
priorities work that we've been shaped
by another millions of years that but I
think math is a really nice example
because that's an example of what we
call stereotype threat where girls from
a very early age believe themselves and
teachers who are teaching them also
believe that girls don't do math can't
do maths find maths hard and so it's
that that informs their choices later on
and interesting Lee in terms of the
question about biology
we've now with neuroimaging and wasn't
my study but somebody's paying
somebody's salary to do this
shown that stereotype threat can also
change the brain so that if you're given
a maths problem and it's framed in
different ways your brain will process
that information differently so it's a
really nice example of yes it's biology
but it's biology which is being molded
from a very early age by what's going on
so another I mean these things have been
shaped down the corridors of time
evolution narrowly speak yes but am i
right in understanding at this
dimorphism this tremendous difference we
men a female body shape is a relatively
recent I mean Paleolithic graves and
very early grave so women it's pretty
meat and beefy because of the very tough
life they had physically and when we
domesticated ourselves into human beings
from an ancestral differences what temp
we have no problem I would say longer
probably over two million years is more
reasonable time and certainly we've
changed we've changed and one thing is
we become less time Orphic in some ways
than then our ancestors and in some ways
but let me just talk about this point
about similarities and differences it's
pointless to ask our men and women more
alike or more different from one another
there's an infinite number of ways in
which any two things can be alike or
different from one another the only
sensible way to ask it and this is not
what hide that paper you mentioned does
it's not what anybody does when they're
trying to show that there aren't many
sex differences the only sensible way to
ask it is we're given our evolutionary
understanding which is what created male
and female and created those differences
where would you expect to find
differences and that's the only sensible
way to ask it so you would expect to
find differences in competitiveness you
would expect to find differences in
interests and people in living things
and when you look at those you find
they're alike you don't expect to find
differences in number of arms and legs
or heads and it's pointless to make that
list of things in which we're alike so
that's just a very simple methodological
point and it's and that is the only way
to look at it to a sensible way to get
an answer how I like our different are
we and then you can start comparing as
you said the dimorphism with our
ancestors and with other living Apes and
so on may it make another pretty um
jeana's very keen that we shouldn't talk
about sex differences out in the open
because people get it all wrong and
start exaggerating and so on and people
use the biology if we say there are
male/female differences they use the
biology for sexist purposes yes if they
do criticize the sexism not the science
you need the science in order to
understand how males and females are
living together in the modern world what
our real differences are how to help
females remedial II with maths for
example because we aren't on average
innately as good at it as males so all
of these things are very very important
to do and may I say it isn't just out
there these these benighted people who
assume that put a sexist gloss on this I
talked about science you then apparently
repeated what I said you said I said
women shouldn't go to university or
something like that you use the word
should you use the word should I just
saying like that I talked about 18th
century quotes not you said I was doing
the 18th century stuff I said it was an
18th century mistake you said I was
talking 18th century you said I was
talking 18th century what I what I was
saying all right let's leave that I'm
just saying I'm just saying it's really
absolutely crucial to distinguish
between what is and the policy we need
what Simon was saying it's absolutely
crucial but it's also crucial not to
assume that you can just will not really
bother about the science because it
makes a huge difference - good or bad
policies and so you're saying then that
the localization of cerebral function
differently in men and women's brains is
a 21st century mistake is that what
you're saying no I'm saying the
assumption that there are differences is
an 18th century mistake if 21st century
we have the evidence to show that there
is very little difference and there's a
phrase which had to be careful using in
the context size matters so we know that
on average men's brains a bigger than
women but that's because men are bigger
than women and when we correct all of
the brain structures that we can study
the volume of the brain etc it turns out
that size is actually the aspect which
contributes to the differences which
we've seen so you could say oh there's a
male/female corpus callosum once we've
looked into cranial volume as its called
those differences disappear the size of
the brain not the sex of the brain and I
think so that's a 21st century step
which people sometimes ignore and I mean
I've talked to people who said you don't
have to be a man to have a masculine a
male brain so I said why do you call it
a male brain then why don't you call it
a logical brain or a
systemizing brain or something what why
I think it's the term male and female
which then feeds into this idea that
there's a dichotomy which informs all
sorts of things which it doesn't
why didn't you correct them about the
dichotomy then and say there are males
and females and these attributes are
distributed characteristically
differently across males and females
yeah yes but but in or in doing that
you're also really denying that there is
dichotomy of
males and females across which these
things are distributed not in the
characteristics I think are important in
determining where women are in the world
what they can do the choices they can
make etc and I think that's that's why
what I'm saying
what can buy what you to take us out of
this mess of what seems to because a
woolly uniformity they are heading
towards well again to bring it back to
why it matters
um you know I gave the example of
children with autism and why is it that
males seem to be more at risk for
developing
offeror forgetting this diagnosis and
that led us to in our research to look
at the role of prenatal testosterone
which we could measure during pregnancy
and to see whether that was elevated in
children who go on to develop autism so
this is I think I think starting off
with an observation that the two sexes
show differences in behavior or in
likelihood of for example
medical conditions might lead us to look
at sex linked aspects of biology
hormones are just one genes might be
another so that we can begin to
understand mechanisms that give rise to
the behavior it's not to say that
environment postnatal learning
plasticity isn't just as important but
some of those very early biological
factors might be might be helping us
understand why the two sexes and
experience risk differently
so how much of this research
biologically is being taken into the
testbed of the real world I mean other
people out there doing brain scans of
women before and after appointment to
CEO jobs and things like that
I mean is that a realistic way of doing
it am I just reinforcing this unhelpful
dichotomy unfortunately lot of that
research things like neuro marketing and
things like that
does it come up with any useful truth
City I'm very keen Ziff you expertly go
inform this synthesis there is an
interesting and relevant study where
they looked at girls who with particular
spatial cognition scores so ability and
spatial processing and they then let
those girls have an intensive six to
eight weeks experience with tetris so
they measured the brains before and
after little tetris is a is a visual
spatial game where you have to predict
where shapes might go into spaces and
the shapes cascade down and you have to
guide them into a plan the idea is that
you build up a wall with no holes in it
etc tell what my spatial cognition is
like but the idea is that that it's been
shown that if you give somebody that
kind of experience you can actually
change the brain I'm not saying that we
should all go out and play Tetris become
taxi drivers or jugglers but I think
that is quite a useful way of
demonstrating that if your skills at a
certain level you can change those it's
not you know you haven't shrug your
shoulders and say I was dealt a tough
hand you know with the in the brain
stakes so one last question before we
throw it out to the audience and that's
this and I don't know how to put this
one to you first really if we do succeed
in accepting my colleagues here
suggestion that the overlap is much
greater than the difference and we do
succeed in divorcing this biologically
oriented research away to the more the
social agenda and looking at this the
real world who seems so important to me
because a doctor what will the world
look like in say 50 to 100 years from
now from from your point of view I mean
could I ask you to sketch out a you know
sort of an evolutionary cookie the
direction we're heading in yes obviously
our evolution isn't going to change and
100 years no evolution deals in 800
million and so on in front of well more
it's more its thing not 50,000
well it's a small thing why are small
things and so in a hundred years men and
women the differences between men and
women won't have changed in the sense
that they will still be the same evolved
differences but I hope that by then we
will have a more considered more
informed understanding of what those
differences are and if we care about
them turning out as differences in work
in education in any sort of achievement
that people want will know how to go
about it by starting with the fact that
we're different not pretending that
we're the same pretending we're the same
leads to disastrous policies and attempt
to get 50 50 % everywhere which is a
most ludicrous policy because it's done
in the name of trying to prevent quotes
discrimination because it's assumed that
it would be 50/50 everywhere otherwise
it's not and let's hope that by then
policy will be informed by science yet
the views of the two and where we're
heading I say that in fact I don't agree
and in that the problem is what is it we
want to be equal is it just numbers of
men and women and I think that's a
mistake because there's an assumption
building on that stereotype that having
50% of your frontbench
should be women why and there's an
assumption that those women will
therefore bring empathy networking
caring etc well I don't think Margaret
Thatcher was possibly a very good
example of that so what you really need
to say what is it we want let's discover
what underpins the particular skills
that are required and make sure that we
can identify those people who have them
or people who don't have them need them
if there's a way of introducing them so
I think trying to get away from this
idea that it's male or female could be
more useful Simon last but last comment
is that obviously what as we go forward
into the next 50 years we're not going
to be playing with people's hormones or
genes but we would we could be playing
with for example methods of teaching and
other kinds of intervention if so so if
we want for example and more girls to
be feeling confident in mathematics
there's lots of things we can do in
terms of classroom techniques so biology
is useful Hastur